who's more fun than watching that guy
Johnny Tapia was smoking crack in
between fights again I don't mind a
killer killer and you love that big
Tapia rooms hot and cut with cookies
finest Albuquerque's fine Johnny Tapia
wasn't murder we were talking about him
he was smoking crack between I mean he
had big coke problem and he was between
fighters and still and still a world
champ there's a documentary on him movie
Mimi Vita loco me Vita Loco it's great
oh yeah Johnny Tapia is tremendous life
they're gonna make I think a movie about
I don't know who plays a guy like there
he is that's Johnny Tapia my rocks
playing Johnny tapa oh you know speaking
of the rock you know well what we do is
there ever enough
is there ever enough that did that you
go maybe I'm gonna dial down the need to
sell something today is it ever enough
that's what I say all the time I
disguise in Palma you know somebody told
me so I've been doing it in my informal
study of like people
it's literally like it's always all this
pot hey man hey and then it's a hey by
my particular hey these are my shoes Hey
after a while I feel like [ __ ] you
you're a fake yeah it's like I'm sure
you're a great guy and I probably would
have a different tone if he were right
here but I would still say the same
thing imma go when's it enough yeah
hate to kill it this is matter I never
know I never got a word I'm signing this
never knows it's my thing when's it
enough guys go home but go home [ __ ]
home after what this is like it's the
promotion never [ __ ] in France I mean
it's just like at what point do you and
then the movie promotion and then the
tequila promotion and then you tie in
all the promotions it's like it's only
hot man I mean he made 60 million dollar
who gives a [ __ ] for a walk in the sand
Lana what you know yeah you were at
Peter Thiel's house until it's got more
money than that guy lives in a
three-bedroom house he's not obsessed
with the money yes with doing [ __ ] he's
boring he's not trying to sell you
[ __ ] tequila while selling you things
but bothering those guys like George
Clooney who you don't see all up in your
face with an uptick in tequila stuff and
he sold all that he's like I'm good man
well the amount involved with a piece of
a company and he would see this as not a
an an an Integra like
a life that's associated with some
regard for there's a kind of integrity
that isn't that but you just every
[ __ ] thing is a sale it's weird well
and he seems like a great guy he's also
a great well he's I don't know but I'm
sure I've heard him talk he always seems
like he gives a [ __ ] so good a bull and
he cares that good but he's great but
whether the thing is also the amount of
he's good at drugs that he's the amount
of extra steroids a he taking but what
don't we all know this yeah I hope so
but I mean some people like how muscular
do you need to get here it's a very so
that's this thing right yeah a superhero
in all the movies like yeah after
there's you can't you cannot not but 10
years ago he was just he was awesome to
his mother's body looked fantastic as
big you look at the idea that you need
to be that big
right well I'm saying his career it's
exploded because he's that guy you play
hurt yeah right nobody old who how many
other people can play that guy for
Hercules that I use he just had a great
sense of humor he was a giant guy who
could oh yeah absolutely yeah yeah now I
feel like he's overdoing it I feel like
he's just doing what yeah like he's just
so veiny until some good movies wow I
mean that's a lot that's a lot of veins
it's always this you know when you're
coming up and you're trying to gain
attention you're trying to get some
leverage in the business you're coming
at things you're doing what you can a
guy like that like how much how much how
much you now you're selling me [ __ ]
tequila
you saw me 13 movies in the last two
months now tequila dude Ashton the fair
consume in Columbus Ohio this Friday
spectrum CBD the best I'm gonna start
with that I guess I'm this weekend buy
your tickets for tomorrow Friday and
Saturday you're taking off but that's
different in it like what from what a
comic does or like that what we do here
it's it's different than you're also not
the rock if you made 13 billion dollar
grossing movies and then you're trying
to hold on to ideas hold on you know
hold on it comes to be and Brian goes
hey men yeah here's I yes race goes hey
you find a kid will give you Brian each
10 million right there's no social media
right
you finally get my dates on the spot I
don't have a phone that's right sir I
might be gone yeah I'll be like Bruce
Wayne you see me zoom is far from you
and I would take off yeah you would
never see me a good social media I buy
your car I'm taking back to New York
oh yes right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]